皆さんこんにちは、道元です。今日は、いつもと違う感じの動画を
作りたいと思います。今回は、オフィス・ツアーの動画になります。
以前にもこのような動画をアップしましたが、オフィスがかなり
変わりましたので、新しいものを作ることにしました。
そして最近この昇降デスクを買いましたが、大変気に入っていますので、
これを作ったDAISHIN工業様に連絡をさせてもらって、
なんと、今日の動画のスポンサーになっていただきました。
ですので、後でこの机について詳しく話します。
その前に、それ以外のものについて先に話したいと思います。
ドア付近から
カメラの上にちゃんとしたマイクがついていないので、
携帯を持ち歩きながら撮影します。
まず皆さんが気になりそうところは、
これは何？
なんで壁が完全に真っ黒なの？
ってところかな
実はこれ、防音シートで、
天井を見ていただくと、
Amazonとかで買える標準的なフォームスポンジのパネルが
見えると思うんですけど、
1万円くらいでそこそこ大きいパネル16枚くらい
買えるんじゃないかなと思います。
でも音を吸収するといった防音効果はそこまでなくて、
最近はあまりないんだけど、結構前に気を遣わないといけなかったのは、
双子の娘たちがすぐ隣で寝ているときに動画を撮ることが多くて、
実は壁を防音にしてもらったんですけど、
それは、音があっちの部屋にあまり行かないようになるだけであって、
この部屋の中ではエコーが響き渡ってしまうんですよね。
そういったことを防ぐために、こういう風に
天井一面に貼ってあるパネルを使ってみました。
少しは良くなったんですけど、
十分だと言えるほどではありませんでした。
僕の友達、Tokyo Lens の Norm が
こういう防音シートを持ってて、
おすすめされたので、買ってみました。
見ての通り、この部屋の壁は全て実質的に遮断されていて、
このiPhoneで録った音源では伝わらないかもしれませんが
すごく静かです、全く音が響きません。
床に絨毯も敷いてありますし
これで動画撮っている間に娘たちが起きることもありません。
でも当然、前から使ってた背景を残しておきたかったので、
上の方を見てみると、壁に沿ってフックがついていて、
そこからシーツがつるしてあって、
おまけにこのパネルもつるしてあります
このパネルの前に立って、向こうのカメラで撮ると
普通の壁の前に立っているように見えます。
本当は本が乗ってる小さな切り抜きなんだけどね
じゃあ次は、カメラを机の方に向けて、
動画を撮っているときにはどんな感じか見せたいと思います。
ここに、Elgatoの…
マルチ…　いや、マルチマウントじゃないな
ちょっと名前思い出せないんだけど、
ここに土台のディスクがあって、この棒に繋げて、
カメラがそれに繋がってて、
そしてここに、大きい、フラップジャックFotodiox…だったような
概要欄にリンク貼っておきます。
ここに照明があって、かなり大きいので
これ点けるといい感じに照らされます。
これプラス天井の照明があるので
これが基本的なセットなんですけど、
今、友達がオリジナル版のBlackmagic Pocket Cinema Cameraで
撮ってくれていて、
それが2つあって、
一つは、普段机のセットで撮る用で机の方に接続してて、
もう一つは、YouTubeのコメディ動画を撮るためのカメラ
マイクはBlue Yetiのマイクで、標準的なUSBマイクなんですけど、
今まで使ってて、このマイク結構よかったので、
机の方のマイクもBlue Yetiマイクです。
動画を撮るときに、前はここにMacBookを置いてて、
しばらくMacBook Proを使ってたんですけど、
顔のこの部分が照らされるようにしつつ、
画面に表示された台本を読んでました。
でも最近はiPadを使っています。
台本を見て、台詞覚えて、カメラに向かって言って、
また台本見て、撮り終わるまで繰り返します。
これはKORGのスタンドで、
音楽やってる人向けのものなんだと思う。
前のアパートでよくやってたのは、
この仕事に真剣に取り組んでなかった頃、パソコンを
隣にあった食卓に置いたままにしてて、
歩いていって、台詞を見てちょっと考えて
戻ってきて言おうとするけど忘れて
またパソコンに戻っていくみたいな
だからこれに1万くらいかどれくらいだったか払った甲斐があった。
それでは少しこの机について話す時間を設けたいと思います。
というのも、僕は普段スポンサーのコンテンツをあまりやらないので、
過去一年でひとつやったくらいでしょうか。
でもこの商品がすごくすごく気に入ってて、
自分のお金でこの机を買った後、会社に動画のスポンサーに
なることに興味はないかと連絡するくらい
そして承諾してくれた。
前は幅180cmくらいの普通の木の机を使っていたんですけど、
この机よりも長いですね。
ここら辺までありました。
ここに機材をすべて置くにはそれくらいの長さが必要だと
思ってたんですけど、
ちょっと整理整頓したら、150cmでもなんとかなるって気づいて、
でもその机はスタンディングデスクじゃなくて、
スタンディングデスクでもないのに、かなりぐらついてました。
重たいiMacに、2つの強力なVESAマウントアダプタがあるし、
Elgatoベースディスクに、重い照明と、PlayStation、
Elgato Key Lightもあるから。
キーボードを打つだけでも、机はかなり揺れていました。
でもこの机は、今のスタンディングの設定でも、スタンディングで作業するときはいつも110の設定にしているんですけど、
揺らそうとすれば、少し揺れるんですけど、
キーボードを打っているだけのときは、全く揺れません。
やはり、これだけのものを乗せているので、
安定性は重要です。
もしこれがぐらぐらしていて、
なにか落ちたら自分のビジネスに大打撃だ。
僕は夜か娘たちが寝ているときに仕事するので、
静かなスタンディングデスクを入手することが大事だった。
モーターを作動させるとき、この机は静かだという
レビューがAmazonで多かったです、Amazonで買ったんですけど。
この静かさは聞こえるか聞こえないくらいだと思います。
この部屋の外からはこの音は聞こえないと思います。
かなりの減音対策をしてるので
本当に静かです。予想以上に。
そして一番低い設定（65cm）から
まあ、少なくとも自分にとっての一番低い設定の72cm なんですけど、
そこから115cm(夜にエアロバイクを漕ぐときに使う高さ)までに引き上げる
のに10秒ほどしかかかりません（一番高い設定は120cm）。
このスタンディングデスクのすごくいいところは、
デザインを選べるところで、
実はこれ木製ではないんですけど、
見た目が木製で、触った感じも木なんです。
ここからの方が机の構造がよく見えると思うんだけど、
ご覧の通り、脚が結構太いです。
一緒についてくるケーブルクリップも鋼の部分に付けて使えます。
木製の机ではそれは出来なくて、
前の木製の机では穴をたくさん開けないといけなくて、
ケーブルの整理がとても大変でした。
ここで全部クリップで挟めるので、
立っていても座っていてもケーブルは視界に入ってきません。
ツーバイフォーの板があって、
木を挟むVESAアームで机と挟んであって
机と木の板がこう直角になってるからそこに延長
コードを立て付てあるのできれいに整ってます。
もう言ったかもしれないけど、僕はいわゆるYouTubeのハッスルで
しばらく自分のケアをしていなかったから椎間板ヘルニアになってしまって
それで動かずに1時間以上座ってると痛みを感じるんです。
パソコンの前での作業が多いので、
自分にとってはかなり重大な問題になっていて、
座って、今もそうなんですけど、ベビーシッターが来てくれて、
やっとこさ仕事するぞってなっているのに1時間後には
作業をやめないといけない、座るのがこれ以上耐えられなくて。
この机のおかげでそういったことを心配しなくてもよくなった。
30分作業したら、立ち上がって30分作業して、
エアロバイクを漕いで、FF7を30分遊んで、
これをAmazon ジャパンで見つけた理由の一つは、これは幅
180cmのオプションのある数少ないデスクで、
先程も言ったんですけど、前のデスクが180cmだったので、スタンディングデスクも180cm必要だなと思ってたんですけど、整理整頓したら150でもなんとかなるって気付きました。
これを作った会社はDAISHIN工業で、約10万円しました。
おそらく全部特注だと思います。
多くのレイアウトから選べて、
さまざまな太さ、デザインから選択できます。
それもあってか、注文した日から届くのに3週間くらいかかりました。
Amazonで買うなら、ギフト設定で選択しなければならなくて、
メッセージの欄にデザイン(机の上の部分)の名前や脚の色など
無数に選択肢があるのでこちらに書くことになっている。
購入した後も会社が連絡してくれて、これが本当に欲しかったものですか、
再度確認してください、大丈夫でしたら発送しますと連絡してくれました。
これを自分で組み立てるのに1時間くらいしかかからなくて、
自分は組み立てたりするのが苦手で、よく物を壊したりするんですけど、
これを組み立てるのは苦ではありませんでした。
そこまで難しくはなかったです。
前の机のみたいに大きいものを買うときとは違って、
包装にそこまで圧倒されない。
最後にこの机について話したいのは、新しいバージョンを作っている
らしくて、スマホのアプリに繋げて、
立ち上がらないといけないよとか、
立っている時間の目標の通知をしてくれたり、
上げ下げもアプリからできます、確定ボタンを押せば。
また、机の上に直接コンセントの差し込み口があったり、
これはないけどケーブルを通す穴はあります。奥の方に。
個人的には、きれいにしておきたいので机の上にコンセントが無い方がいいです。
この机は素晴らしいものなので、
日本に住んでいる人なら見てみることをおすすめします。
自分の仕事環境を無限大に快適にしてくれた。
痛みを感じながら仕事することがなくなったからね。
最近の視聴者さんの日本語を直す動画を見ている人は
分かると思うんですけれども、
これがそういった動画の背景のセットで、
これの中にはPhilips Hueの電球が入っていて、
これは「営業中」だから、うちは営業してますみたいな提灯です。
ここには寿司の看板があって、
YouTubeの楯と、千と千尋の神隠しのカオナシと
そしてこれは最近ゲットしたんだけど、
ファイナルファンタジーVIIの舞台裏メイキング本
FF7リメイクとオリジナルは今までで一番好きな
ゲームで、人生について多くを学んだ
これはちょっとした小ネタで、
数人しか気付かなかったと思うんだけど、
この提灯には、「永平寺」と書いてあって、
禅僧である道元が開山した寺院なんです。
彼は曹洞禅、曹洞宗という禅の宗派を提唱した人物で、
高校で結構それらについて学びました。
その頃は日本に関することはなんでもかっこよくて、
さらに仏教や禅にハマった時期がありました。
同じメーカー、会社の棚を2つ使用しています。
一番上にはケーブルなどがあり、
その下に重要な税に関する書類や保険証書
そして台本を読むためのiPadがあって、
日本語の音声学の本がいくつも
これらの本は基本的に日本語の発音に特化した本です。
慶応大学で学んだ日本語の発音と高低アクセントについて得た知識と
10年以上も日本で住んできたという経験に加えて、
ここにある多くの本を参照してPatreonに上がっている
日本語の音声学のレッスンを作っています。
今机の上にあるものを紹介します。
ここにPlayStation 4があるんだけど、
中古のPS4で、FF7リメイクを遊ぶためだけに買いました。
一つのゲームをするためだけにPS4を買う価値があるのかと
しばらく考え込んでいたんですけど、
自分にとってどれだけこのゲームが大切だったか忘れていて、
これ多分Twitchか、過去にやったYouTubeのライブ配信で
言ったかもしれないんだけど、
ゲームに電源入れて、
オープニングムービーが始まってものの1分でボロ泣きした。
いろんな思い出がよみがえって。
週に3回は運動するようにしているので、
下の方にFlexiSpotのエアロバイクがあって、
このモニターに向かうようにこれをセットアップしてます。
この机をもう少し引き上げて、
エアロバイクを漕ぎながらFF7を日本語設定で遊びます
お父さんだから、残念ながら基本的に時間がない、
特に双子の娘がいるとね
20歳とか25歳で若かったら、
そこまで大きな問題ではないだろうけど
健康問題は結構ひっそりと襲いかかってくることが多くて、
特に自分みたいにクリエイターをやってる人々は
自分の健康に対してあまり注意をしていない。
だから、こういった机の下のエアロバイクだったり、このスタンディングデスクは
クリエイターにとって本当に大切な投資になると思う。
机のセットで動画撮るとき、つまり皆さんの
日本語のリアクション動画を作るとき、
今友達が持ってるカメラで撮るんですけど、
このElgato Multi Mountに接続して使っています。
今は彼のカメラ、本当は彼のカメラでこの動画を撮る予定だったんですけど、
ここに繋げてどういう感じか見せられるようにしてます。
なんだっけ、Elgato Key Light が上にあって、
すごくよく照らしてくれます。
一つ軽く触れておきたいのは、今カメラの中に入っている
SDカードに録画していて、
自分の、または一般的にYouTuberのワークフローには
なにかを待たないといけない段階がいくつかあり、
動画のレンダリングを待たないといけなかったり、動画の書き出しや、
写真を取り込むのを待たないといけなかったり
僕にとって待ち時間が一番長かったのは、カメラにある
動画をパソコンに取り込むことだったんですよね。
約1時間くらい録画して、
だいたい60か70GBのファイルになります。
そしてそのファイルをよくある小さなアダプターで
パソコンに転送させると、だいたい20分くらいかかります。
たくさん調べてみたところ、これについて知って、
これはUltraStudio Recorder 3Gと言って、
小さな箱みたいなもので、本質的には
キャプチャーボードみたいなものです。
カメラからHDMI出力端子をこの小さな箱に繋げて、
そして、パソコンからのThunderboltケーブルを
このキャプチャーボードに接続して、
そうすることで、ファイルを直接パソコンに録画することができます。
録画し終わった瞬間にはファイルは既にデスクトップにある状態になります。
一つひとつの動画にかかる20分の作業時間を省くことができます。
何年も仕事すると考えるとその時間は大きな節約となります。
外に出てvlogを撮ったりはせずに、家で撮るのであれば、キャプチャーボードは
ワークフローを各段に速くさせることができるかもしれません。
ほぼ全て説明したと思うので動画はここまでにします。
何か質問があれば下のコメント欄にお願いします。
いつもサポートしてくださって、ありがとうございます。
次は普通のコメディの動画ですので次回お会いしましょう。
いつもとは少し違っていて、ちょっとひねってあるけど
それは次回のお楽しみと言うことで。
皆さんまたお会いしましょう！